I don't have a horrible
cartoon.
I want to make the people standing in
line
at Saint Peter's gate.
They go to heaven and you know,
there's the rich men in the,
the poor widows and,
and Saint Peter's asking them,
how much money did you make and that,
and then the poor people are going to
hell say,
that's my horrible cartoon.
You know?
And that's like,
should not be the measure of a good
life.
Um,
my,
I think it's,
I think it's being true to your,
uh,
I,
I really think being true to your,
uh,
family and friends to whatever world
you've created around yourself,
the real world,
what,
who are the people you care about?
Um,
it's not,
I don't think,
uh,
I think you can try to make the world a
better place,
but I think too many people I feel doing
that become,
you know,
Mrs Jelly beans and they just,
they throw themselves into that and your
screw over the people who are actually
around them.
Um,
I think causes are,
uh,
are nice,
but the,
your greatest cause needs to be your
immediate circle.
Okay.